مصائب ولبنان تتوالى اقتحامات فيضانات
وحريق في مرفق بيروت الجماهير السعوديه
تستعيد لمباراه المنتخب المصري مع المكسيك
والايرانيون يحتفلون بهزيمه منتخب بلادهم
امام امريكا في كاس العالم هذه الاخبار
وغيرها نقلها لكم من قناه العربيه اهلا
بكم
نبدا من لبنان حيث شهدت البلاد خلال
الساعه 24 الماضيه حوادث كبيره كان ابرزها
الفيضانات التي اجتاحت منطقه كسروان
ومدينه جونيا الساحليه حيث دخلت المياه
وعددا من البيوت ودمرت عددا من المركبات
وفي منطقه جبل لبنان اقتحم مذيع بنك
الاعتماد واحتجز الموظفين مهددا باحراقه
ان لم يحصل على امواله لعلاج زوجته
المريضه بالسرطان فيمن دلع حريق كبير في
مستودعات داخل مرفا بيروت نتيجه اشتعال
حاويات تحتوي على اطارات المطاطيه وفقا
لماذا ذكرته تقارير محليه
في اخبار المونديال وقبل لقاء المرتقب بين
المنتخبين السعوديين والمكسيكي ضمن
منافسات المجموعه الثالثه بكاس العالم
نظمت الجماهير السعوديه مسيره خضراء تحت
اسم لابسين الابيض وارواحنا خضراء في
بوليفارد لوسيل في قطر المشجعون ارتدوا
القميص الرياضي الابيض للمنتخب السعودي في
ما شهد
التجمعيه والحماسيه للمنتخب هو ما يعكس
الحماس ويشتغل في الكبيرين للجماهير
ومساندتها القويه للمنتخب في مباراه
المصري امام المكسيك امال كبيره بتاهل
الاخضر للدور ثمن النهائي
في حادثه لا قد انتشارا واسعا على
السوشيال ميديا احتفل ايرانيون في عدد من
مناطق البلاد بهزيمه منتخبهم امام
الولايات المتحده وخروجه من منافسات كاس
العالم وهذا باطلاق الالعاب الناريه
والاهازيج وتوزيع الحلوى ناشطون قالوا
انما فعله الكثير من الايرانيين جاء
لايصال رساله نفاذها بان المنتخب يمثل
النظام الايراني ولا يمثل الشعب على حد
قولهم فيما اعتبر اخرون ان هذه الاحتفالات
هي احدث علامه على الاستياء المتزايد من
القياده الايرانيه في وقت يواجه فيه
المتظاهرون عقوبه الاعدام
في خطوه وصفات بالتاريخيه احتفت الاوساط
الطبيه بالاعلان عن اول عقار فعال في
ابطائي التلف الذي يصيب الدماغ نتيجه
الاصابه بمرض الزهايمر شبكه بي بي سي
البريطانيه اشارت الى ان هذا الدواء الذي
وصفه العلماء بالاختراق العلمي ينهي عقودا
من الفشل فيما يتعلق بابتكار علاجات فعاله
للخرف فيما وجد الباحثون في دراستهم التي
نشرت في مجله نيو ايرلندا الطبيه ان
الدواء ابطا من تدمير المرض للدماغ بنسبه
27% بعد تجربه اجروها على حوالي 1800
متطوره
وفي خبرنا الاخير تحقق حلم عائله امريكيه
بولايه تكساس بالالتقاء بابنتها المخطوفه
منذ اكثر من 51 عاما صحيفه دي تايمز
البريطانيه اوضحت ان القصه بدات عامه 71
عندما ارادت سيده تشغيل جوليسه اطفال
لرعايه ابنائها حتى تتمكن من الاحتفاظ
بوظيفتها لكن حصل ما لم يكن في الحسبان
اذا اختطفت الجليسه ابنه مشغلتها التي
كانت تبلغ حينها عامين لتبدا رحله البحث
عنها حتى تمكنت عائلتها من العثور عليها
عن طريق الفيسبوك ومن ثم اجراء فحوصات
الحمض النووي الرسميه التي اظهر التطابقا
مع العائله